so the first part of the problem we're
now experiencing in the country is we
still have trump running around saying
uh corrosive and damaging things about
our democracy and it's a real problem
the reason we worry about it is because
thousands of people still go to the
rallies and the guy still has millions
of followers and i'm gonna play some
clips for you of interviews done
with trump rally goers on saturday in
conroe texas and this is really about a
lot of things
what what i'm gonna play for you is very
disturbing
if there's kids in the room you may not
want them to see this stuff
but this is about education
this is about untreated mental illness
in some cases you'll see that it's about
the weaponizing of vulnerable people by
politicians it's about a lot of
different things but at the very top of
the list it's about this kind of
coalescing of people with the absolute
worst instincts
to allow authoritarian strong men men
wannabes like trump
to put in place
any vision of the country even one where
there is no due process there is no
freedom of the press we lack all of
those things under this grand vision of
people like trump and the people either
because they don't understand or they're
distracted with other things or because
they're mentally ill
they allow it to go on because if trump
wants it it must be okay
let's just start with this first clip i
won't even introduce it do your research
on this right here the world economic
forum klaus schwab this is bigger than
trump this is bigger than any of us is
bigger than any politician this is a
global plan to enslave you and your
family and pretty much make you poor and
dependent upon a global government
something i like to call evil so it's
even bigger than that no it's spiritual
warfare i think it's written about in
this book it's a really popular book a
lot of people read it i think the bible
bible revelation right you can't buy
herself without the mark so is this
a religious delusion is this mental
illness if you're watching you'll notice
a guy with a sign behind these folks
that says mass formation psychosis which
is sort of the new meme for them
it can become very difficult to discern
what is merely a psychotic break and
delusional beliefs and paranoid
schizophrenia
and what is
a religious nut and what is someone
who's just been brainwashed i mean
i'm not joking about these things it's
very tough here's another one of these
everybody's happy and everybody's got
one goal and that's
for everybody to love everybody and
save our save our country live their
best lives
unpopular opinion i'm a flat earther so
uh
like i just been talking to some people
today telling them why i believe what i
believe it's like i try to find common
ground on uh because most people would
agree that we don't come from monkeys
and that we didn't big bang right so i
can tell you guys this guy is definitely
this guy definitely didn't big bang i
would i would i would concede that
but um
this is
what do we make of that is this is this
a sick person or or what is it
if you can find common ground with
people then you can start building a
foundation of like what truth is you
know
so and let's go bring it
right so sort of it quite a contrast
right we didn't come from monkeys we
didn't big bang
let's find truth and let's go brandon
here's another woman
um
asked about
who knows something she's holding a huge
trump head
it's like uh four feet tall the size of
trump's uh
that's the size of this trump head that
she's holding
so that's what all this is
love it is this your first trump rally
no sir i went to um
uh tulsa oklahoma in april
and it was uh freedom fest and clay
clark's reawaken america tour
and it was about educating people that
some of the ideas that we're going
through need to be researched a little
deeper there's way too much false
information
that's true
the problem is she's coming up on the
wrong end of it and you need to educate
yourself on health educate yourself on
your water educate yourself on what you
put in your body
and that's a personal choice
that they should not have the right to
take that away from us
absolutely i couldn't agree more
keep using your voice keep keep
speaking whenever i want to know the
truth when i want to educate myself when
i want to dig deeper i go to someone
who's holding a four foot tall cardboard
trump head i mean it's just perfectly
natural guys um then he goes up to some
kid
and you can tell this guy's
been been read the riot act on fake news
listen to this time what do you think
about the way the media just goes for
broke on their lies
i think
that people should stop listening in the
media right and watch y'all's stuff
because y'all don't lie about anything
right and watch
republican news i mean
there's some
news networks that are just democrat in
their brain watching the people right
just watch republican news and right
side broadcasting and then you'll know
the truth you'll know everything um
lastly or no not lastly i got a couple
more for you here's a woman in a box she
wore a box and she
really misses trump's tweets her entire
life used to be wrapped up in trump's
tweets
he was kicked off twitter i mean i miss
those tweets do you what are you doing
every single day of my life that's what
i spent doing for five years what a sad
life huh literally i mean it's
everything i did and i miss them
terribly and the people miss them
terribly that's the sad thing hear me
out again another business idea
everybody misses trump's tweets her
entire life for five years went around
trump's tweets all right now i don't
know if it goes from funny to scary
maybe it wasn't even funny to begin with
here's a woman who thinks that joe biden
was actually killed two years ago at
guantanamo bay and that there is now a
fake joe biden
why why are you here supporting trump
what's your motivation he's our real
president thank you very much and what
what what are you basing that on what
the fact that the election was stolen
and he's our real president
is fake and he's you know the real biden
was assassinated uh
in 2019 march of 2019 so it's only there
so listen to the number of lies trump's
the real president trump actually won
the real biden was assassinated or as
she says and assassinated two years ago
i i agree with you with the part that
there's no way those demanding machines
they've already been proven all over the
world
what was crooked the dominion chains but
trump's having 40 50 60 000 people at
his rallies before the
presidency
or for the election and biden that's 50
people and that includes
the people there for security and the
media all together and he supposedly got
more votes than obama correct so
how do you explain that because the
american people know who are really
president is we're fighting for america
and we are going to
save this country and the world
and people know that uh by the pedophile
and they don't want to go see it because
they know he's a pedophile creepy joe
crazy joe's a pedophile did you know
that he had an island his family has an
island near epstein like eight miles
away i don't know his family is called
water island
yeah his own family
is like he has like a um
kind of like a little neverland kind of
like michael jackson
michael jackson was saving the children
[Laughter]
even that the guy tries to agree the guy
goes yeah biden's got a pedophile island
kind of like michael jackson's
neverlander she goes no no no no no
michael jackson was not doing anything
wrong he was saving the kids
michael jackson i thought for years he
was on the bad side he's not he was
saving the children and when he plays at
the inauguration
when michael jackson comes in place for
us people are going to realize that so
she thinks michael jackson's alive
you think so he had a big queue
neverland he had that big queue saving
the children trump helped him escape
that was part he helped john f kennedy
junior escape princess diana escape so
john f kennedy jr and princess diana are
also alive how how is this even you know
we're up against the political movement
that's filled with people with no
connection to reality undiagnosed and
certainly untreated mental illness at
least in some cases um here's the last
one about a satanic system that we're in
that is pure evil good versus evil it's
not left right it's not democratic and i
believe that too right now you know what
i'm saying i'm saying i think i think
this um uh a system that we got going on
right now it's a satanic sister uh
system yeah and let me tell you
something and let me tell you something
i believe i believe satan is on his
j-o-b man he is on his j-o-b and we need
to be getting on with our j-o-b we got
to take this country back from god man
we got to take this country back for
jesus christ man yes amen yes darkness
so um always uh you know it it's really
a unique mix that is not common in other
countries of
lack of education
religiously based delusions
conspiracism
and in some loose sense
mental illness that can include paranoid
schizophrenia and other things that's
i'm not diagnosing any particular
individual we're saying the movement
has all of those things within it
how do you even
run against such a movement that's a
really difficult question to answer
we'll have some of these clips on our
instagram which you can find at david
pakman show